on continue avec les beaux mecs le
deuxième c'est patrick dubé
m
patrick bonsoir ressortir ouais ça
marche c'est super ambiance
que fais-tu fait bon voyage voyez les
jusqu'ici à travers leurs affaires à
l'espace temps j'ai fait un super voyage
j'ai enfin trouvé les femmes sauf voyage
je n'avais une à droite à gauche il y
avait peint ouais tu étais où quand je
t'ai téléporté dans cette émission mais
j'étais ailleurs m'a complètement
ailleurs
je suis complètement aya tombe à rien
ouais ça un restaurant bar discothèque
est pas très longtemps qu'ils auraient
ouvert il ya jeudi dernier j'ai même
pensé je t'attends patrick laroche
encore un coup tu as match sera plus
tranquille
encore oui là je peux faire tout
atteinte à leur accueil dans la totale
ces deux
je peux par la junte et encore on
n'arrive pas à s'en débarrasser de ces
c'est comme les virus dans les siècles
qu'il était plus et si moi je peux pas
passer ton bien sûr d'ailleurs dommage
dis moi tous deux succès à quel âge
avant-hier n'ont qu'à attend laurent tu
te canon ça c'est clair
tu as eu du succès que j'ai commencé à y
arriver à paris j'ai eu au premier tube
avec quoi c'est quoi ton premier de la
musique à l'arrivée de housses arrivé de
suisse
nous avons toujours fait avec mes
parents ah bon tu habite toujours chez
ses parents
ouais c'est quoi tes parents mon père et
ma mère ma mère est de s'occuper de nous
et mon père s'occupait de télévision de
vente des télés à plein de gens à mon
métier que c'est comme le père c'est à
croire qu'en suisse tous les parents de
chanteurs vente des télévisions parce
que le père de stéphane eicher ils en
étaient les visions aussi tu sais où tu
vas lui en suisse un nouveau record en
suisse pour être chanteur il faut avoir
un père qu'ils vendent et les chaînes hi
fi donc eh bien je vais bien
tu as écrit les lundis au soleil bon
avoué après la musique à kloten à
museler ou alors comment ça s'est passé
avec moi ça parce que oui mais j'avais
un voisin jeu qui était qui était un
décorateur à l'époque et il imitait très
bien que françois alors tous les
dimanches il venait j'ai composé une
musique
et puis on a trouvé le thème du lin
les oreilles que tout va mal
parce que j'ai oublié de te dire c'est
que ce décorateur qui était imitateur
c'était le coq n'a pas connu encore est
cette fois que là c'est sympa et
l'audition chez claude françois qui
s'est passé comment pour les lundis au
soleil pour l'industrie c'est assez
marrant parce que je crois qu'il y
croyait peut-être pas trop hein à la
musique donc que j'arrivais c'est grand
c'était sa grande maison de production
flèche hôtel particulier et j'étais
convoqué par un secrétaire charmant qui
s'appelle gérard louvin et il avait bien
du chemin c'est incroyable je belle
fille tuée dicton quand louvain et urée
et après
et après donc y arriver si met au piano
j'ai commencé à chanter et là on m'a dit
il vous entend par des petits interphone
qui étaient placés avant lui n'était pas
de rester dans son bureau au dernier
étage et il appuyé comme ça sur un
intervalle et il est allé réaliser je
descends tout à l'heure j'ai des choses
à faire je jouais je travaille
exactement 80 ans et l'a dit quand il a
entendu at il entendu le refrain
j'entends du coup wen est arrivé dans le
volant en voilà
et leila deen enregiste demain il est
parti à londres teza rapporter beaucoup
d'argent ça me rapporte toujours
toujours bah oui mais faire comme j'ai
des plans de bêtes
ouais enfin ça lui sera portée des
tonnes de dollars et non de dollars par
an en france à des français sûrement
hanter plus gros tube ça a été un élève
america où sont les femmes c'est le plus
gros c'est à la mairie l'a fait avec un
sol j'ai fait 13 disque d'or 13 pays
c'est a rapporté 13 millions de dollars
parce que nous voyons aujourd'hui
seniors
tel est le credo est dessiné des
nationales
oui
accueillis tout ce succès tu es parti
aux états unis oui et c'est là que tu es
rentré quand même un peu dans le trip
pop star non ah bah oui c'est le trip à
l'américaine c'est c'était avant le fric
ça risque pas de m'arriver
c'était comment c'est quelque chose que
je pensais pas qui était vrai je pensais
que c'était dans les films
la maison de disques qui te met à
disposition une limousine avec chauffeur
sur 24 heures tu peux faire ce que tu
veux
il faut être à l'heure où télé faut
essayer en tout cas l'air au tlm était
dans la ligne mais c'était dans le
stress c'était qu'un jour c'était à
madrid de même incité à barcelone
ç'a duré combien de temps cette ville à
un an et demi ouais après j'ai stoppé
c'est quoi le meilleur souvenir de cette
époque là aux états unis
ouais c'est quand j'ai eu mon appart à
central park
parce qu'avais la veille à une terrasse
la vue sur tous ces milieux là j'ai dit
ça y est je suis maître du monde là non
pas vraiment mais un peu quand y'a pas
de honte à être le maître
maintenant je tombe du même nom soit
qu'il ya un moment où il est le plus
plein ils ont pété ouais c'était à
refaire je referais la même chose
exactement la même couleur blonde comme
ça tu ferais n'étions pas les mêmes
traits dans les racines ne sait pas que
sur le lourd naturellement nigérien
à
et sourit bo yibo mais chef lieu comme
prévu c'est patrick juvet c'est pas de
sa faute il est né comme ça il est mieux
je vais vous eh bien là c'est ce qui
dérange prends ma place non non non non
non tu y en a qui doit rester ses toiles
excuse-moi quasi clodo qu'est ce que
c'est ça c'est complètement délicieux
dérégler la machine et l'homme avoue va
bien vous allez il a quasi reste du
boulot
suivant les cumuls regarder n'importe
qui qui arrive je vais te dématérialisée
maintenant oui c'est non mais à la
beauté intérieure mais là elle n'a pas
le temps la beauté intérieure la fin
demain à peu j'ai été dématérialisée ne
me regarde pas comme ça non mais je vais
aller ou abattus au retour mayer ok
d'accord on met toi bien au fond du
voile à jamais comme ça n'est pas peur
tu fermes les yeux mais non mais bien tu
es mais bien voilà c'est ça la il pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de ligne
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux